you spend lots of time on the phone  looking for information jumping between  tasks and we asked ourselves how can we  get you quick answers two quick  questions without leaving context how  can we help you get things done in as  few steps as possible so we're working  on a new capability to assist you in the  moment right when you need it wherever  you are on the phone we're calling it  now on tap so now on tap as Dave  mentioned takes advantage of new  functionality in the Android M release  so we'll be rolling out in em and I want  to give you a quick preview of what it  looks like what it can do for you when  you turn the feature on so I have Neil  up here with me hot off the press demo  so you want to see it in action yes all  right let's do it so here he is  listening to Felix and you wonder like  me what is his real name ok Google  what's his real name Skrillex this full  name is sunny John Moore who knows  quick answer the quick question without  having to switch context